[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas sur la chaîne de mac
line garito mais c'est les 50 golden
donc on est content oui tout le monde
n'est pas là mais on a réuni un panel de
gens pour regarder des vidéos qui est
donnée d anecdotes à la fois
croustillantes tendre et drôle
ouais mais également un big up à tous
ceux qui ont pas pu venir à savoir
eléonore cost justin le potier autres
goni gobain mcfly cailleteau à pied aux
mairies continuer ce que savent les sur
ical sur les cas je les dis je trouvais
suricates
est-ce qu'on est prêts on est prêt et
ouais quoi on remarque jean rouch haut
la voix c'est adrien milieu le corps
c'est moi incroyable et j'ai la
gestuelle de la vermine lms de st c'est
dingue parce qu'en vrai je sais pas si
quelqu'un a deviné ça c'est ouf
et j'ai ma meilleure crif cette coupe et
ça c'est acquis mais les costumes et les
costumes c'est grâce au travail énorme
charlotte qui travaillent à la
production de golden moustache qui a
vraiment passé trois semaines à ne pas
dormir et à contacter des gens qui font
des costumes que les cosplayeurs des
passionnés et des deux c'est un mec qui
s'appelle eric
qui a fabriqué lui-même son air de s
atteler jean six ans qu'il est dessus il
continuer à l'améliorer
ouf en revanche les chiens il était
extrêmement mignon il nous a fait
chialer de dominion aller obadia et un
beagle quand même aussi à antoine beagle
qui a fait tous les fixes tous les tous
les habillages tout le graphisme des
trucs qui tourne animé tous et antoine
béguin
il a un nom de traîtres et vous entendez
peut-être la petite vanne de carlito à
la toute fin
c'est karl ritter qui a réalisé le
sketch aussi peut-être pourrait-il être
mis sur d'autres sagas qu'on poursuit et
bien c'est possible
post 1 tu as vas-y chante le générique
de la prochaine saga qui sera dans le
bureau
[Musique]
seigneur des anneaux histoire en fait d
entre vous et moi c'est qu'il ya
longtemps c'était dans une radio suisse
est en fait j'avais une chronique vidéo
avec blaise burning up et en fait on
faisait des interviews un petit peu
décalé comme ça et je suis content parce
que ces basses et série qui a bien
marché que tu continues sur mashaie mais
c'est sorti cinq épisodes 300 vols d'air
venez vous abonner il ya une anecdote
aussi c'est c'est que deux épisodes
c'est pas mal chic et là c'est mc fly
wii est en fait la vraie histoire c'est
que
vacher avait eu un petit souci aux
testicules j'ai passé on peut le dire on
est là le médecin bon c'était rien
finalement mais voilà exaucé qui ont
d'abord et après tu dis je sais pas si
on peut le dire ouais et personne ne
remarque mais sur la semaine à hyper u
ça c'est du yop
c'était du yop à la fraise mais c'est
très drôle un autre qui chie sur un show
succès l'assuré soit le vous et moi
le titre a été trouvé par adrian meyniel
qu'à l'époque je suis très content de se
faire sentir et de pouvoir la continuer
du coup on fait quoi pause déj
ça commence avec de la baisse souvent
c'est qu'à la base je voulais la faire
cette scène bah oui alors d'où vient
cette petite idée de sketches de k-pop
là bas
je pense comme beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnes
on a vécu cette situation où on est avec
une avec une fille
et personne ne capote et j'ai vraiment
rencontré des
des mecs des espèces de petits groupes
de kyle personnage
il ya vraiment quelqu'un qui m'a dit bon
au pire tu fais une et jacques faciale
et ça c est ça c'est vrai ça alors ce
qui est très très drôle en plus c'est
que ont tournées de nuit ça c'est pas
drôle non mais en fait ce qui est drôle
c'est qu'il y avait des gars tu sais
comment ton aide de nuit c'était un
vendredi soir qui venait faire la fête
quand on est vrai que j'ai mené toute la
nuit en attendant ils vont tourner près
d'une porte et il était complètement
arrachée et se mettaient derrière nous
mais je m'en bats les couilles
on va peut-être en train dé que l'aspect
drôle c'est que on a mis un couteau
sabatier parce que le réalisateur ça
flanche essentielle et ça nous faisait
rigoler là aussi est dit les années
passent les choses changent et est une
amine golden là et jouer une pièce que
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est clair notre
faim s'est tourné dans un quartier de
paris
l'animal il ya beaucoup d'activité mais
un bijou à l'histoire c'est un vendredi
soir ça picole beaucoup et c'est
vraiment une rue de la soif en fait
cette petite constat capote à voir les
cantons tout simplement qui ont été
faites exprès pour le pour le sketch
mais non je vais essayer ou agnès on a
pensé à tous par cabaye allez c'est
parti comme ça surtout pas parler j'aime
beaucoup ça parce qu'on peut dire ce
qu'on peut dire aussi c'est qu'il ya du
contenu que vous faites pour la chaîne
golden youtube il ya du contenu question
votre chaîne et qui n'est pas forcément
sur youtube c'est vrai
je vais la mettre sur la tête de ma mère
je vais la menace et la bb la tête de ta
mère alors ça alors ça c'est pervenches
travers d'un truc que je balançais
j'imagine et juste des des mecs
douze agents asvp badass parce qu'ils ne
sont pas du tout dans la vie qu'il a
mise en scène carlito charlie total esso
diomat fake exactement on ne fait pas
plus de chance à grand monde mais on lui
a fait confiance et on regrette pas non
je me permets n'ayant rien fait sur ce
sketch de vous féliciter ce que j'adore
ce skate je trouve ça et c'était une
super journée de tamié comme ça on se
fait chier les gens adorent les gens et
on débat alors bon on y regarde et les
gens y croyaient qu'on était vraiment
père manche alors que non alors que des
gens ont cru vraiment freddy prenant au
théâtre des gens aussi je vois inconnue
il s'est pris une balle là je hurlais
après un moment dans l'oreille de justin
qui vraiment d'un tricheur on l'a même
vu justin je suis là voilà c'est là
c'est la voix son lasso produit un
moment là pas mis un bout de mouchoirs à
l'avènement que ses cheveux unique bah
c'est ce à quoi tient le plus vouloir
garder amie céline a déjà signé à nice
se lancer tout est dans la langue c'est
très fort tous ces comédiens et là on
voulait qu'un mec qui disent calzone le
saut vous allez voir le saut le saut
danis qui est très particulier les deux
sont pas ou mal j'ai découvert après ça
que moi j'arrivais l'après-midi ont été
découverts dans les roches je t'emmerde
[Musique]
guy hoquet bref réaliser encore par le
très bon tome evra c'est marrant c'est
que n'importe quoi sérieux ils l'ont mis
là parce qu'on voit pas mais les voix
grâce à ma barbe
m on peut mettre ce qu'on veut par
exemple dit viens truc mettre autre
chose
étiez vous à l'aise franchement oui
comme le temps passe que vous êtes des
mondiaux à celle des vrais comédiens
étaient gênés la lâche une caisse et
après tu es bien là elle se rend compte
que ses mains [__] c'est un bien pour
ta bonté moindre et une scène très
spider man est ce qu bras tu crois que
tu as un pour moi
kerra [__] mais j'avais pas compris
envers fait l'effort tu peux la touchez
pas c'est bien combien sur sa copine en
naissant bern ots la bernie alors que
cela nous dit bernard léger 54 et là
regardez pas très fourni
on a sabré là je me porte en fait c'est
pas si facile et simple ou est-ce que ce
regard calme serait pas un autre visage
ah oui il a des cas sacrément barroso
pour avoir gardé son sourire calmes et
dédicaces aussi à tous les figurants qui
viennent sur les tournages
simon la célèbre voix qu'on voit c'est
la preuve qu'on est là on fait du crâne
sinon qu'est-ce que je lui rentre là il
est envoyé
qu'est-ce que cela annonce a confessé le
sketch [__] regardez là tout d'un coup
j'ai un cancer alors que j'ai pris juste
une fois pas quatre maladies la fin de
ce sketch est une des femmes en affaires
et de tous les sketchs super mignonne
madère et c'est ce qui fait que c'est
les meilleurs fin du siège sionisme est
ce à dire de quoi d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote and his band est regardée
lagarde
la csq est sur la chaîne de grève vous
avez votre propre chaîne non non
si une chaîne s'appelle nice est prise
et en plus on peut le dire puisque là
quand la vidéo sans tarder bon y'a la
saison 2 qui vient de caen à tout pile à
dire on a déjà bien sûr les gens la
suite c'est du porte à porte chez les
gens pour dire non vraiment c'est vrai
sur celle de vidéos non là maintenant
c'est jojo donc mon deuxième sketch en
tant qu auteur et acteur pour toi tu
étais pas bien gros coup de fatigue j'ai
mis du temps les et hume à l'essai dans
la résine et et j'essaie d'adapter parce
que j'avais envie qu'ils se
l'approprient aussi il ya plein de
petits détails
il en fait si on regarde les vidéos à
droite c'est plein de clins d'oeil à des
générations aient su peser sur youtube
et ouattara ajouté plein de petites
idées comme ça vient on crée donc
c'était ça où l'attendait à première
vidéo ci-dessus paris puis on a profité
d'avoir une foule en délire
parce que j'avais besoin d'avoir des
vrais youtuber telus dont lui et donc à
doc sim qui est un vrai youtuber qui est
cardiologue qui cartonne vraiment que ce
qui fit date pour l'occasion a fait
jacky d'agrumes il faut savoir que les
t-shirts jacky l'agrume existe que j'ai
connu et faire gagner mais je suis nul
en organe je ne sais plus qui ai eu
l'idée de mettre une vraie souris c'est
une très bonne idée mais c'était 4 est
dégueulasse d'avoir les auditions genre
d'idée en fait où tu les as tu fait
géniale et la souris c'est une souris
morte à la plagne ans freddy gladio avec
ddb
rasé et en fait je fais plus vieux rasé
finalement pour faire plus jeunes et
finalement que j'ai pris dix ans le
chroniqueur web côté web designers
d'audi a lancé ça d'ailleurs c'est une
blague
c'est une blague que tu as trouvé sur
place sur le fait que je te rendent pas
le téléphone
rendez compte que là ça devenait très
premier dogues message en sortant des
montants qui avait pas de blague parce
que parce qu'en plus le pire c'est qu'à
la lecture quand on était en réunion
d'auteur ça me faisait rire ce texte
en fait on s'est rendu compte que que tu
vois là dans la situation en fait
c'était vraiment moins drôle là flaubert
aussi qui m'a dit tu m'as bien diriger
aussi pour pas trop tomber dans le
pathos par moment et tout parce que
c'est compliqué en fait quand tu quand
tu composes un personnage comme ça en
étant en hiver donc en fait en hiver
pour les gens qui qui savent parler
tournage c'est que du coup tu as plus
que tu as beaucoup moins d'heures de
tournage parce qu'il fait nuit des
heures 30
je suis très fier de ce sketch est très
content de l'avoir fait à golden et on
m'en parle souvent en dédicace et où
c'est le le truc qui à qui revient
souvent on me demande de signer mes
petites tartelettes et autant que moi
j'ai kiffé le faire aussi je sens
c'est moi le verdict il y avait un
instrument âge fatigués ce moment je
n'arrive pas à dormir chez eux les gars
plusieurs autres cellules dans ces gens
on sait pas qui va pas viser
alors je sais pas ce que j'ai en ce
moment j'arrive pas à dormir mais tu es
victime d'insomnies c'est faux ça [__]
c'est pile de titres du sketch qu'on va
regarder ces faits par super lancement
alors assez tonique pas mince imputé à
l'époque où j'avais des cheveux qui a co
réalisé ce sketch avec toi stéphane
carnot là on l'a réalisé à deux hommes
pleins d'effets spéciaux en boldak avec
le même doigt alors si alors là où c'est
bien voilà cette scène là alors ça qu'à
la dernière prise il y en a eu
pas mal parce que extrêmement évidente
pour des raisons évidentes je ne sais
pas si bien que ça et non non non non et
que le but c'était vraiment bon bah
ouais à d'éventuelles violences
mais là c'est la collision ne gênerait
pas de longues et belles gt lt td et
commente une visiteuse sketch qui est
sorti de rappel avant la vidéo de maman
demain sony cette idée parce que je
dormais tout simplement j'ai eu l'idée
la nuit il vous a fait une idée la nuit
et moi ce qui m'a marqué c'est ce qui
m'énerve et quand j'arrivais pas à
dormir c'est que je me paraît enfin que
j'avais l'impression de parer à moi même
et que c'était moi qui mets là il y
avait vraiment ce côté d'une voie qui
n'arrête pas de parler que du coup c'est
ce que j'ai voulu montrer d'eux en gros
je m'auto fait chier dans la vidéo et
légendes
ah ouais mais c'est ça revient aussi
parce que j'étais content d'avoir joutes
le 2e st just t'es tu dors mieux
maintenant mais je ne sais pas très beau
mais j'en suis très content ce plan je
l'aimais beaucoup
enfin voila je suis très content de ce
sketch est très content de l'avoir fait
avec léonard où tout est ce que c'était
une belle expérience humaine
mais l'excès en finale et voilà l écoute
pas dormir dix ans le bureau des rêves
qui a maintenant quatre ans je crois qui
est très vieux et dès le début une
erreur parce que vraiment les bonnes
noires écrase
jingle non j'étais content parce que
c'était un des premiers super quel
casting ya lui c'est adrien dans des
petits rôles
mais il ya aussi simon astier david
salle julien pestel la série justin mes
potes et la soeur de celle de potiers et
ça devait deux mecs à la base et je vais
même vous dire que ça devait être yann
colombie à la place de l'islam le côtier
et ça n'a pas pu se faire pour plein de
raisons pour les choses pour les cheveux
principalement simon joue très bien les
connards et j'ai beaucoup de mal un jeu
autre chose qu'un pur débile et
personnels jour un gros beauf qui parle
que de cul et ça aussi je l'adorent dans
ce registre
lorsqu un truc qui me faisais moi aussi
c'est mon côté un peu vieux tonton comme
ça mais moi ça m'évoque vraiment les
films noirs des abbesses et larressore
ce nom là la réponse vous avez dit
imaginer le film on peut leur aux
couleurs de trois lycées foch avril à la
musique de fin et de théo bernard qui
est mon frère et sa preuve et ça c'est
une photo de moi petit avec mon papa
et l'idée est celle animée rodionoff qui
était le directeur d'écriture à l'époque
et je le remercie parce que jamais ce
sketch j'osais pas aller là dedans dans
le deuil
je voulais surtout parler de fait ne pas
trouver le sommeil et il m'a dit non aux
foyers à lézignan j'aurai donc j'étais
parti sur une rupture et il m'a dit non
mais c'est bon là puis on s'en bat les
couilles
ça c'est fâcheux doit grand ouais moi
aussi je suis très fier et on diffuse un
sketch du golden shoe faut le savoir
aussi c'est ton premier dans ta dans ta
fibre comme le syndrome post rupture
c'est sa faiblesse et sa non mais ce qui
est chiant quoi simon juste pour dire
deux mots moi je sais c'est devenu un
coup de foudre c'est quelqu'un que je
considère comme un comme un qui a mis
quelques uns de mes grands frères de ce
métier je vous mets mais voilà je vais
en a on a beaucoup travaillé ensemble on
voit souvent c'est un vrai un vrai coup
de foudre et je les y aller et je laisse
us et 5 fois
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si les abonnés je faisais un 5 1 fait
j'en fais je remercie
aw c'est ce qu'ils sont trop petits
oeufs dans cet immeuble
on remercie claude r ouais
allô oui studio beagle
[Musique]